Okay, we're live.
OBS was being weird for a second.
going to do something a little different
today.
Well, we're going to do uh I'm on a
little bit earlier than normal. I'm
going to do a
I don't know two three hour uh morning
session here. however long it takes me
to go through some basic
basic results, little bit of research,
get a few more experiments queued up,
that sort of thing,
and then I've got uh some business in
the afternoon to attend to
So, the main thing uh that I have not
been able to figure out yet,
this is a breakout. Okay,
this is the result of a a normal sweep
that I ran.
So, what I can't figure out, right, is
why I did this one separately.
And I've ran way more experiments here.
And for some reason, it's not finding
this point. And I don't understand why
not.
Let me just make sure this is not doing
something incredibly weird because uh
OBS keeps showing as like going off and
on again. Let me just make sure it's not
making like a million stupid like
10-second stream posts.
It just did. Yeah, it did the one from
before. I think we're good now.
Hang on. Let me just make absolutely
sure cuz it keeps it it's doing
something weird today. It keeps flashing
on and offline. and then we'll get to
research as soon as I'm sure it's not
like spamming my entire my entire thing.
Okay, it's not this is the same stream.
We're good.
Okay, so this is the main graph that we
care about, right?
Um
this is let me grab epic pen.
So
this curve is supposed to be the cost
for Prito Frontier.
And then there's going to be another one
which is if we do like
if we do uh cost and steps, we're going
to get one that looks like this
hopefully. And if we can do this
automatically, then we'll have uh we'll
be in a really really good spot
essentially for all the stuff we need to
do from here.
So
now basically my question is why the
hell does this happen, right?
And uh I have
today a chunk of today and a chunk of
tomorrow to be here doing research. And
then I'm off for a couple of days and uh
I will be relocating
for the season.
I mean, the only thing that's really
weird about this set of hypers, right,
that we found is the really low value
function clipping.
I think everything else is pretty
reasonable, right?
It's like
Yeah. So, like I am sweeping these. I
didn't like cut these ones out.
I should really be able to figure out
though
So, I'm just going to try to like make
some plots for all of these and then
we're just going to see if we see um you
know if there's any like quirks in the
way this sweep is covering the space of
hypers
and uh if that's not so if that doesn't
work. I'm going to expect that there's
like some weird thing going on with the
machine and I'm going to try it on the
faster machine to see if there's like
some dependence on time.
That's what we're going to do.
I just have to make sure this thing's
really not
on stream, right?
Okay.
Okay, we already have this one. We
already have this one.
Honestly, it might be a fun little side
project to make my own um just like
puffer plotting thing that's faster and
easier than this.
Just I know how much time I would end up
spending on that if I did.
and like
I don't know.
I wonder if I could actually make that
like something broadly useful though,
right?
The only thing I don't know about that
so like let's say I were to just put
together a little plotting thing in Ray
Lib and it would be super fast. Um would
it actually be able to
like would I actually have a decent way
of loading in data if I did that?
That's the thing that I don't really
know.
side gig. Replace wand and Neptune with
a
Be funny.
All right. So, this is everything. Um, I
don't even know if this is going to run
at a reasonable Is this going to be fast
enough
Okay, so here is our full plot of
everything.
Well, we definitely are getting like
parameters that are outside of the
expected range, right?
In fact, like this is kind of the
healthier range here.
Oh yeah, this is Wait. V
range/clipip coefficient.
Did I miss this?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I didn't even notice that the clip
coefficient is that low. Holy.
Okay. I think there's something screwy
with my internet today.
Hey, Jess. Welcome.
Hopefully this stream is stable enough
for me to do like a couple hours today.
If not, well, it sucks. But yeah, so
Jess, I finished my training block, so I
get a little bit of rest so I didn't
have to like run and do my whole lifting
thing this morning.
I get a couple days rest.
right. I mean, this was at least this
was a good finding. So then
I guess the next question is going to be
like
if we go to Neptune, right?
It's actually like not the case that
they all have terrible clip co-ops,
right?
Like what about this guy?
What if I use this one as a reference?
Oh, they all are. They're pretty much
all like one or the other is screwy
though, right? I guess this one is like
a stable looking one
that's like slightly lower.
Yeah. So, this one doesn't even have any
weird hypers, right?
This one actually has like pretty normal
hypers.
Okay, let me set something up real
quick. Right, let me set something up.
Um,
first of all, I forget what it was that
I uh I ran here. I ran like some
experiment on this, right?
I think it was like some pong thing.
Okay, I ran this like this little pong
sweep
and we actually get some cool results
out of this, right?
Yeah. Yeah, we got some really nice
results out of this, which is
Oh, yeah. This is the purto frontier we
wanted, right? This is, look at this.
So, we actually get it under a 3se
secondond solve with 2 million steps.
I think that's including frame skip. Or
you can spend 20 seconds and do it with
1.5 million steps. Right.
So, this is I mean we we're
investigating like totally the wrong
ranges here, I think.
But like this is the Parto front right
here. See
this is the curve that we want. So we
just we did all the experiments over
here
but uh we have what we need.
Okay. So, you tried this. You tried
this. That's fine. This didn't work.
And then nothing important.
I think that literally all we want to do
with this
is we just want to run multi sweep on
this.
We're going to run basic multis sweep on
right. So, we're going to run this on
that node. Um,
this would actually kind of suck if this
were the case, right?
Ooh, Kinbert sent us a really cool end.
Look at this.
This looks like a hack of the drone end,
but it looks really cool.
Holy,
that actually seems really bad if we
have things that get screwed up
depending on the machine, right?
I'm going to have to want I'm going to
want to look into that in more detail.
Let me use the restroom real quick. Be
back in a couple minutes.
Taking French toast. No, the steak the
uh the steak was good. The French toast
was like cut way too thick.
But at the least at the very least, I no
longer feel absolutely terrible all the
time.
Um, let me read. Uh, just sent me a
bunch of stuff. Let's see.
Better a chess engine or player is more
likely the game is to be a draw.
More draws doesn't mean the player is
better.
Yeah, that that's the problem with this
whole thing. Like the problem with
selfplay Jess is actually like it's not
even about the dynamics most of the
time. It's just measuring stuff is a
pain because yeah, you have to do ELO.
like at least now you understand the
thing about it, right?
We have code in there somewhere, Jess.
Like there's this old ELO code thing
that I worked on. It's just it's kind of
a pain.
I sweep too long, they find hacks rather
than flying better. Yeah. So then you
need to patch hacks
cuz like your your end should not have
hacks in it.
This is the key mystery. I think
right now the key mystery I'm trying to
figure out is why I ran like the
traditional single node sweep on the
fast machine and I get like a bunch of
solves that look like this. And then
when I run a huge sweep on the slower
machines, I get like this clean curve
that seems to match, but I don't
actually get solves
before the competition ends. That's why
invert. I've never done a hackathon.
I hate being under time pressure for
just about anything.
How's the world of RL doing? We've got
science going. I mean, all the stuff I'm
working on and that I've been doing in
the last week is kind of just a bonus,
right? But like, I mostly was here over
the summer for business. I got one good
block of research with a really cool
result out of it. I started on this a
little bit early and like we got at
least some business done as well.
I hit I like smashed all the fitness
goals as well. So, pretty like pretty
darn good productive summer. So, this
stuff is just a bonus. Like, this is
going to get started in earnest in a
week or two when I'm back at the farm.
I'm just trying to figure out if like,
you know, before then I can at least get
some understanding about how this stuff
should look.
I almost am wondering if there's like
some cost differential [ __ ] going
on, right?
I ask you a few questions. Yeah,
absolutely. I mean, the main reason I
like it's the main reason I stream,
right? So people can ask stuff live.
Research block look like uh it's mostly
this type of stuff like science of RL.
We want to have a very good
understanding of this. Uh depends what
it is then, Parkco. But yeah, you can
ask. I'm not going to go nuts for you
asking questions.
Uh
it's
so pretty much yes we want to be able to
understand the cost like the compute to
data trade-off in RL generally as well
as like intrinsic environment difficulty
uh model size scaling stable
hyperparameter regions all this type of
stuff
genetic algorithms. Ooh. Um,
actually, so Parkco, the Aife conference
is next week.
It's in like Kyoto.
Uh, I would just like go look up look up
stuff that's at AIFE and like look up
the labs that are producing that work.
Yeah. What you should do is you should
go get familiar with the literature and
then like try to get contacts in labs
that are doing work you're interested
in.
It's a conference that's devoted to a
lot of stuff around that artificial
life. There's lots of genetic al type
stuff, but like you kind of just have to
get familiar with the research space,
right? Because labs are just publishing
research. And the way that you figure
out what labs are doing stuff you care
about is just by being familiar with the
research space.
and Ernest answered that I mean
evolutionary algorithms are they're
really cool. It's just like nobody has
found a good way to scale them at all.
Right?
So like in my mind there's not like
there is nowhere near as clear of a like
how do we make uh evolutionary
algorithms generally useful for
learning. Like there's no clear way that
we do that uh compared to how there is
one for RL.
Like technically what you're looking at
right now has like very mild genetic
algorithm inspiration, right? Like this
PTO optimal search is a form of genetic
algorithm with extra stuff built into
it.
But yeah, Parkco, I if you're asking
about PhD programs, if you're in like
undergrad or masters or something like
that at the moment, it's you really want
to just get very familiar with the
research space. Like the best way to if
you really want to do a PhD
then like the way that you do a PhD is
by like having already done half of a
PhD before you get there,
right?
Alpha Evolve. Honestly, still haven't
looked through all of it. Like
language model stuff
is great. Well, that's just where the
conference is. I don't know. You could
try to like you could try to go like get
yourself a registration and like go
there last minute if you can afford to
do so. like um
you can also just like try to figure out
the what's being presented there and see
like who you can get in contact with.
Masters in data science. Okay, cool.
I mean the thing is the world's a big
place. There are labs doing lots of
crazy things, right?
Um
it's more the research experience
that rather than the specific
credentials, right?
How much time have you like spent really
deeply thinking about a specific
research topic and getting to know stuff
in that space and like doing your own
primary work
Let's say that across the board here,
right?
I guess it's technically possible with
this that like
maybe across the board
uh the 4090s are just like several times
slower and that like skews our sampling
because we do actually sample points
based on projected cost. So that
actually could change the results of a
sweep from machine to machine.
I thought we normalize it though
algorithms for eight months
I mean it's pretty easy to just get
involved with like a lot of the research
that's out there.
Like professors can sometimes be hard to
get a hold of but their students are
usually really easy to get a hold of.
Yeah, gen alos are fun. It's just
nobody's figured out a way to scale them
to more than a couple thousand params.
You're about the only expert I know
these days. Well, I mean, that's kind of
the whole thing, right? Like, they're
not that many researchers that are just
streaming all their work.
is
now science can be very isolating.
You kind of either need to like be the
type that enjoys that at least to some
extent or you need to get yourself
involved with like a larger group of
people who are actually smarter than
that you respect which can be hard to
mind.
Channel got taken down. You should not
be having your channel taken down.
Streaming research.
what's going on here?
We should have like at least a few data
points, shouldn't we?
Yeah, there all sorts of experiments
going on here.
is that like region based? I don't think
I've ever gotten like a
like a Chrome ad
with like adult content on any normal
sites like
I love Kyoto. I think it's like in a
week or two though.
So, go take a look at that.
Taking me 3 days to get a working
attention model. 550k parameters four
agents. Oh, hey FBR. Uh, a useful data
point would be how fast can you get a
model like that to run?
sound like a global thing.
Well, I mean, Parkco, like I think ads
are like ads are region based and at
least in the US in the US like normal
websites don't show adult ads like
that's not a thing
Yeah, I education is generally just
rough in general, Jess. Like there's
very very little good educational
content and like really good content can
let you learn things very quickly but
the vast majority of content it's just
like
it's often times not even like if you
are a smart person um and you've learned
to teach yourself many things like bad
course content or like mediocre course
content can be less useful than just
spending your time figuring stuff out
yourself.
10k SPS.
That's awful.
Uploading videos prevent unwanted
content.
Wait, is that a thing in Korea that just
like randomly you get adult ads
everywhere?
The fact that like you can actually use
that targeted is like so stupid.
I don't understand how the hell uh
you know we still have all the streaming
sites are just this prude where it's
like oops you know clearly didn't mean
to show that
like still like take channels down was
ridiculous. This
108 observations per agent. That's not a
lot of observations, man.
What is wrong with this?
This is the port for this is not isn't
Um
medical. That's cool.
I mean that the thing is like
that's that is just how you learn to do
this Jess right it's like okay I did
like my undergrad at Stanford and then I
went to MIT sure I have like the
credentials or whatever but like how do
you think I actually did research you
think that there's just like a like how
to do research 101 for dummies that you
take and then like how to do research
like 202 for slightly less dummies like
no man you just like you sit in your
room you start reading papers and like
you start piecing stuff together and you
do that for a very long time and then
you like try to implement some existing
things and then you try to like make
some changes and make your own things
like that's the process of learning
right
so this is at least running um it's not
doing anything super substantial yet.
I'm trying to think if there's like
anything else stupid I could have just
messed up with this.
This was frame skip at Hold on. 40
million steps, right? Frame skip one,
right?
Yeah, frame skip is one. 40 million
steps. So this is like
this is just one of the ones for example
that we have
right like this is a very clean curve.
We have 20 different runs out of 200
that were able to get this.
So it's like it should be very
consistent.
looks for all the world like just a
normal hyperparameter sweep.
How much stuff did I actually sweep?
It looks like I didn't sweep the policy
size
a mini batches. No.
No update epoch thing here either.
There's literally not even an updates
epoch update epoch thing here at all.
So,
I mean, I guess it is true that the
sweep is slightly differently set up.
my normal
breakfast place is closed for Rashana
apparently. So is the backup place.
Lovely.
Oh, I'm going to have to find somewhere
to get myself food in a bit.
Can Rust be used for RL? You can. I
personally do not recommend it.
We do all our simulator uh all our sim
code is in C.
This thing just bothers me. Like, why is
this happening?
If I can just fix this problem, then
pretty much everything just starts to
make sense, right?
there thing
fast and safe. Not that safe. Yeah, but
like what does that mean? Okay, so if
you have if you're doing a bunch of
memory management and you don't want to
forget to free stuff,
then like Rust prevents you from doing
that. The cost of that is it completely
changes the way that you have to write
your code.
Okay. So, if we just allocate all our
memory at the start and then clean up
everything when the program closes,
there's no memory management to deal
with, right? Okay. And that's what
you're going to do anyways for high
performing Sims. So, like literally, you
just have a bloated language that gets
in your way that to solve a problem that
you don't even have.
He is dramatically simpler and like Rust
literally gets in your way to solve
problems that you don't even have.
How much faster is C compared to Python?
Uh, it can literally be a thousand times
faster just straight up.
And the thing that's obnoxious, right,
is to make stuff even like passibly okay
fast in Python, you have to do all sorts
of stupid complicated stuff where like
you can just write stuff in the simplest
way possible in C and it's just going to
be fast.
And like obviously if you want to
optimize from there, there's lots of
stuff you can do. But like just the
simplest possible thing that you can do
in C is usually just going to be is just
going to be fast.
I don't know. I really do not like Rust
as a programming language. I can
understand it for like some like
embedded systems dev, but for the type
of stuff I do, it's just like not good.
writing hyper sims not covered in your
guide. I mean honestly it's just a
matter of like write something simple
then write something slightly more
complicated and you go from there. Just
do incrementally more difficult
projects.
C will come in handy. C is just like
honestly
simple low-level development skills are
just so nice because okay if you know C
you know CUDA
right
okay if you know C which is literally
just like basic programming you can make
pretty much anything out there you can
just like rewrite it in a tenth of the
amount of code or less and it'll be
faster
it's like this crazy thing where it's
actually very very simple and very easy
to learn, but just nobody knows it and
everybody complicates the hell out of
everything. It kind of feels like a
superpower in some ways.
Golang, it's like fine, I guess.
I'd probably rather write that than C++,
but like yeah,
I don't know. I know some guys that are
like really into Nim, which is also it
seems like decent.
Convert Python to C. Yeah, don't do
that. Just learn C.
Like it's not it's not hard is the
thing.
Like yes you there's few things that you
need to understand about basic systems
but like it's not like C is a harder
language than Python. It like that's not
a thing right language are not ordered
by difficulty.
Well okay some are because some just get
in your way for no reason but C
definitely doesn't.
I still don't know why this happens.
I've been sitting here thinking about
this the whole time and I I'm still not
sure like what the heck is happening
with this.
It's like I almost just don't see how
this could possibly be
how this could possibly be different,
right?
I'm like literally running the same
sweep.
I mean, I guess it's like possible I
broke something totally different,
right?
Yeah. Charcoal
here. While I'm While I'm here, I may as
well just figure out
512 x 64. Right.
I mean, there's almost nothing left for
it to possibly
to possibly do, right?
Oh, well, this is screwy, right? Why is
it doing this?
It's doing the thing where it's stuck at
like the super lowcost solutions. I
suppose
that's dumb.
Yeah, it's doing this stuff over here,
right?
Okay. Well, that could very well be like
a susceptibility of of the core
algorithm.
It's literally built to avoid this
though.
Like this was one of the key things in
the algorithm was to avoid this.
That is the evidence that I needed,
isn't it?
It's that somehow
Well, how the heck would this be the
case, though?
It really I've seen this happen before,
but it shouldn't be possible.
Oh,
well, you're an idiot. That's why,
man. This is why you don't All right.
This is Yeah.
Um,
all right. Well, that's a way to waste a
whole bunch of time. I guess I didn't
spend that much time thinking about
this, but
stupid. I'd forgotten that I'd hardcoded
this. This is why like the thing is this
would have been totally fine if I'd like
run this experiment and then come back
to it like immediately. But I think I
like did this and then I went into SF or
like go took a bunch of meetings and
then I got like distracted.
So yeah, of course this doesn't freaking
work.
I'm surprised it worked as well as it
even did.
We're going to leave this alone for a
bit. We should be fine.
This is like the best possible outcome
in some ways.
Okay, I'm gonna let me use the restroom
again real quick. I'm going to come
back. I'm going to think about some
stuff for a bit. We'll go figure out a
few things um planning wise for what's
next and then I'm probably going to go
take myself to a nice brunch somewhere
because I'm only in Palo Alto for a
couple more days and damn well plan on
enjoying it. Be right back.
So, let's fix this so I never do this
dumb thing again.
Uh, and like literally look, I was on
the wrong machine, so I still started
this thing wrong.
do I or do I not want to make myself a
fancy uh plotting interface?
I wouldn't be surprised if I could get a
an LLM to just prototype.
I mean, I always know not to do that,
but still.
It's like a quick test.
Why does this not autocomplete anything?
That's weird.
Wrong browser.
I mean, I do kind of have like um a five
or six hour plane flight.
Plane flight. Yeah, I got a five or six
hour flight um that I could like hack
on. Like it would be nice to hack on
something self-contained.
So, I guess technically even though it's
kind of silly to like spend a bunch of
work time on this uh at the moment, like
I'm going to have a bunch of time to
work on other stuff when I'm like
basically monitoring all the experiments
for the science stuff once I get them
stable.
And having like a really cool way to
present the data is not a terrible idea,
especially given like literally this
thing that I'm doing now is already
starting to lag.
new Grock like
no idea.
I generally just assume all language
models are bad at everything until
proven otherwise.
This thing is not set up linking
anything correctly.
That is super annoying.
This actually looks This looks like it
should work, doesn't it?
Oh no, you're dumb.
Hang on.
Yeah, I have these ordered wrong.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Hang on.
I I don't know why I did that.
just decides not to link anything.
It's a single file, my guy.
Well,
no. We're not parsing the d the JSON
with Python and having to set up
bindings. That's ass.
Is there like extra flags for this crap?
I like
Is it like using some other stuff I'm
not realizing?
Wait, I don't need
I shouldn't need the C, should I?
What's even in the C? I thought it's
header only.
Oh, what the hell? It has
It's supposed to be a header only. What
even is this mess?
Why does this thing have a 3000line C
file?
Okay. Well, this thing is just still I I
don't understand what the hell
I think this is like a newbie project,
right?
Okay. People have used this for like
scientific viz before as well. Look at
this.
Why would you use the freaking CPP
bindings?
Yeah, Ray Gooey.
I mean, this is definitely doable
though, right?
Like, if I'm thinking about it, am I
crazy to think that this is probably
like the best thing we could possibly do
for Viz
is to just have like some basic thing
like this.
Hello, Joseph. Honest work. Share my
vision. Thank you very much.
Hey, don't be a stranger. All right, we
have all the uh we've got all this stuff
in the Discord. We got lots of helpful
people in there if you're looking to
learn more in RL.
Um we genuinely have people now in the
Discord who are contributing to cutting
edge research who got in with no
experience like a year ago. Takes a
little bit of work, but we're making it
easier every day.
I mean, this kind this library is like
this is a header only, but this is kind
of chunky.
Oh, no wonder this didn't work. It's not
header only. It's like
I hate it when people do that.
If I didn't have to use this, this would
actually be it would be better if I
didn't have to mess with this thing,
right?
How are we doing with uh
this now?
Yeah, this is so freaking slow. Okay, I
guess it makes sense then that we do a
dashboard.
Look at this. Instantly, we're starting
to get better data. Instantly.
All right, that was really dumb. Um,
this will find us some good data points.
You're using AI now. Not really dark.
B in Turkey. Oh yeah, I forgot that's a
thing. Yeah, that's kind of insane.
Is X also banned in Turkey?
I mean, a lot of my other content is on
there and a lot of like the users will
just reply to stuff on there as well.
Um,
ignore the random fitness article.
Okay. Like
you know, a like there's a lot of
content on here as well,
Okay, awesome. Yeah, like in general
there just a lot of people that are
doing stuff with Puffer Lib floating
around and you know uh you can always
ask me stuff on stream, right? But like
there are like when I'm not on there are
a lot of other people and users, right,
that can help you with a lot of
different stuff on um on this, right?
Most of the people that are getting into
RL around here, I don't know your
specific background, right? Most of the
people who are newer are just like they
start by building some simple
environments and getting RL to work and
then they move on to harder projects.
People with like a little bit more
background maybe they try to like do
something uh in like a different domain
of science with RL. There are a lot of
different things.
It's a Billy Billy.
I mean it hadn't even occurred to me
having like countrywide bands for
like what do people even use then?
It's kind of crazy to have Discord of
all things be banned. Like Discord's
literally
It's literally like a gaming It's like a
freaking gaming server thing, right?
That's how it started at least.
And Dark. Um, no, I'm not like I'm
literally using this for
I mean, you'll see what I was using this
for. I was just trying to get a runnable
example that I could build on. I'm going
to end up deleting all this code anyways
That's like That is super messed up. I
didn't realize any country had banned
Discord. That's crazy.
Oh, actually
it No, wait. Discord's a thing in China,
isn't it? Or is it banned there, too?
Get up.
Funny you mentioned that.
Oh, I missed this. Uh same railway
simple custom 2D multi- aent n
same selfs supervised.
Oh yeah. Okay. We have a lot of people
that have done adjacent stuff to that.
Um,
I was at OpenAI right before they
started that as well.
There's like there is a version I think
of that that's like really unpolished.
Yeah, you can definitely make that type
of stuff work really fast in Puffer.
I don't think I so much touch grass as
much as I
do a large amount of
running over grass.
All right. So, this is just me messing
up Rayb somehow, right?
KD trees for agent vision. Wait, KD tree
is for agents vision.
FBR, have you just tried doing naive ray
cast and seeing how slow it is if you do
like decently coarse r uh ray casts?
like you only need a few whiskers,
right?
How often do you stream stream live
coding? Is it a daily thing? I generally
stream all of my research. So, it kind
of depends
on uh what I'm doing. generally like
I'll have blocks of a few weeks at a
time where I do like a full project on a
pretty like consistent schedule and then
like right now for instance right I've
been finishing up some business I got to
do some stuff later in the afternoon for
that um I'm traveling for the next few
days and then like it's going to take me
a bit after that to get back to the farm
because I'm like moving for the season
and then probably once I get there I'm
going to like start doing this stuff a
lot more heavily
So then I'll probably be doing like 40
50 hours uh a week worth of streams
until I solve this problem and then I
chill for a little bit and I like figure
out the next thing.
So I'm pretty much always around. Um the
specific schedule is subject to the
project I'm currently doing.
But yeah, I mean, all the VODs are on
YouTube. I've got like five like 500
streams worth of VODs so far.
Aren't the streams distracting?
Um, yes and no. They kind of are, but
then also if I'm not streaming, I tend
to space out a lot, so I think it
balances out.
Plus, this is like a good way for me to
get uh people involved with the RL and
get people support. Like when I when I
end up being more intently focused on
like heavy dev, you'll just see I get
quieter and I don't answer as much stuff
from the chat.
I should try to implement search.
Um
the thing is the only thing you would do
search for just would be like having a
baseline opponent to play against.
You wouldn't do it for the agent.
Like I think that the thing that would
be really cool is if we could just get
like a clean fast version of chess where
we get like a pretty good agent without
using search. That would be awesome.
like just do pure RL and get like uh you
know get something that smokes me at
chess that just trains on your laptop.
That'd be awesome.
And I am terrible at chess. For the
record, I'm terrible at all games.
I'm actually confused as to why this
doesn't work Now,
Oh, wait.
Is it Does this make a difference?
Like for installed packages versus
No, I'm dumb. All right, that doesn't
do.
Uh, whoops. Let me miss a message. Can
you give a quick starting point for
doing self-supervised autocurriculum
for training two adversarial policies?
Okay, so there are a few different
things here. So self-s supervised auto
like autocurricular type stuff is just
you make an environment that requires
learning that and you make it fast and
that's it. Just any of the custom
environment guide stuff that I have, you
can do that for it. Um the thing for
adversarial selfplay that's a bit
annoying is you have to do ELO type
stuff. We have several different people
trying to build better things to do this
right now around puffer. Uh you can do
it. It will run out of the box, but the
thing is like if you don't have a fixed
difficulty opponent to evaluate against,
you're not actually going to know
whether your thing is improving or not.
So it's usually decent to have like a
scripted opponent of some variety, even
if it's random, just as a sanity check
and then to go from there.
Kevin, let's see. Okay. I thought one
canonical result from Alph Go. You need
search significantly reduce the scale
not pass.
Well, do you think that I trust that
because they couldn't do it that it's
not possible?
Math is the wall I'm hitting in my first
year. Uh gosh, check out my guides then
because like there's some math to what I
do, but I think of all of the resources
out there, my stuff is going to be the
most heavily uh reliant on engineering
over math. Like when I'm doing my own
research, my playbook is 85%
engineering, 10% basic science, 5%
stumbling through math to the best of my
ability.
Like math is the weakest part of my
toolkit.
And definitely don't ask me to do any
stats.
No, not on YouTube. It's right there on
X. So, if you check X, um, I have all
sorts of articles on here, you know,
this is like research. We've got like
some like highle stuff, but then we've
also got guides, right? Like this is
like a a pretty well- read guide.
And this has all of my best advice and
it has links to everything else that you
need.
If you kind of just look around through
my content, everything is there.
Yeah. And then I do the occasional
fitness the occasional fitness article,
but everything else is uh is pure
technical.
Open AI has stats interviews though.
Uh when I went there, they had a very
good interview process. The interview
process was you go present your research
to the entire company
and then you go and talk to a bunch of
their researchers one-on-one for an hour
a piece
and you talk about research, right? You
very quickly get a sense of whether
somebody knows how to do research.
There's not one path to like being a
successful researcher. It's not like,
"Oh, you're bad at stats, so you can't
do research." Right?
That would be like me saying like, "Oh,
hey, John Schulman, you're bad at
engineering, so you can't do research."
Right? Like that guy writes some
freaking horrible code and he's probably
the single best algorithmic contributor
to the field.
It's about leveraging your strengths in
a way that's unique and that hasn't been
like that nobody else can do.
I say as I failed to compile basic C
Uh,
all right. This is just like some dumb
linking thing though, right? Like what
the heck did I possibly do?
All right. Well, this is super freaking
obnoxious, so I'm just going to do it
this way.
H. All right. No remote rendering on
this Okay.
I'll be able to get that set up on my
laptop to play with.
We'll see whether that ends up being a
useful idea or not. But I've managed to
stall long enough that this thing should
have generated some data, right?
super slowly. This is why I started
messing with that in the first place.
How slow this dumb thing is.
And yeah, there we go. So, we already
have an 847. This is our original solve.
Um,
we actually totally should be able to
run something way more substantial now,
right?
I don't know where you heard that from,
Kevin.
Okay. So, given that we know that this
works,
like I'm happy with this is evidence of
this as well.
I think what I'm going to do,
we're going to keep all this data. We're
not going to like do a fresh run or
anything yet, but I want to see how much
this front gets pushed basically.
And I think that the way that we do
this,
I think what we wanted to do, right, was
like
Yeah. So, this is like a way more
flexible sweep, right?
Oops. And this is actually supposed to
be Purto Sweep.
We'll see what that does.
And I also posted the
I posted this what the fitness article
as well from the summer.
And I'm pretty proud of this. Um,
where's the running block?
So, this was the the heaviest week of
this was the last like end of cut week.
So, 46 mile peak week up from 30.
And this was intentional. Um,
no long run on their first week. So like
no runs missed for a six week training
block,
250 total miles.
PRED my 10k time on a very hard course
on like a psychotic cut as well. Didn't
lose any strength.
Yeah, this thing is done now.
And
I'll come up with fun new things to do.
I'm glad to have that done. The last
couple weeks, if you noticed on stream,
I was just freaking exhausted. And uh
yeah, it was from that.
The You look massive in the article. The
webcam angle is deceiving.
Uh, if anything, the web I look I think
I look better in person than with the
the webcam. Like
I didn't have the camera at any weird
angle. I literally have the camera in
basically the same spot that I always
do, right?
I'm not doing mini posing show or
anything at the moment, but that is
that's raw unedited like that is raw
unedited footage and uh pictures in like
mediocre lighting as Hell.
Am I even allowed to do that? FBR, I
don't think I'm even allowed to do that.
I think Twitch has like some crude thing
about that.
Now, the only thing that there will be
is once I get back to the farm, there
will be
um intermittent training throughout the
day.
Yeah.
No, I very much I intended that article
to be like not like Instagram totally
fake photo that doesn't match anything.
That was like I didn't peak for that,
right? That was just the end of the
training block. No peeking, uh, no
editing, like pretty mediocre lighting.
I literally just took my ring light and
that's all I used. And like shitty phone
camera.
Like literally, you can just actually
should I can I do that real quick? Let
me think.
Do I still have it in shotcut
here? Let me just let me just show you
real quick how like utterly stupid
um how utterly stupid editing is.
I didn't even realize it was this bad.
Hang on.
I don't get banned for Here's the
freaking back one. I don't get banned
for
Okay.
So, literally watch this.
Okay. So, literally watch this. This is how stupid editing is.
That's why I posted the raws cuz you can
basically you can basically make [ __ ]
look like anything you want,
right?
Yeah. Literally all I did is I like
super basic color grading. It's just
like you tan yourself four shades and
then suddenly everything looks twice as
good. That's why I post I posted the
raws because otherwise it's like it's
just stupid.
Now the one thing I think that you could
do that's like the thing is a shitty
phone camera is actually going to make
you look worse than you look in person.
So, if I at least had like my normal
streaming camera, like that camera
actually would be like uh that one would
be pretty one to one within person, but
the shitty phone camera kind of just
blurs everything out.
right? Yeah, there is a couple there are
a couple other things I can do with
this. Um,
Yeah. Yeah. So, I have um I got uh
actually I don't think you've ever seen
me at the old facility or the not the
old facility, the main facility, right?
I think you joined more recently than
that, right?
I have a way better setup there.
This is kind of just like the jank
setup.
And first you've gotten I mean I've been
doing ML for a long time, Jess. I've
literally been doing it since high
school. But I was just like looking at
fields of science to pursue and like ML
was the really cool one. I was super
freaking clumsy with lab equipment back
then and like computational stuff seemed
cool.
Yeah, you'll see the uh the main
facility is a lot of fun
and it's like super convenient as well.
I get longer work hours in because I
kind of just get to do a lot of my
exercise throughout the day.
Okay. So, I have on Tiny Puff Zero. I
have this. I need to do this one here.
Uh, I don't know. The weather is
probably cold. That's why in the dead of
winter I go to Florida.
I kind of travel around seasonally.
No, my family has a couple different
places that I crash at.
I think the next thing I want to do with
this,
let's do
Let's do from like one E5
to like
2 E6.
right now we got a lot of boxes worth of
experiments going.
good as well. We got 13 GPUs worth of
experiments going. Um, I figure out
what's going on with this thing
real quick.
No exoth using fake for x11 forwarding.
Oh, okay.
Uh, is there a container thing?
I know Python. Don't understand anything
you're doing.
Uh I mean C is a very simple language.
You need you really just need to learn a
little bit about
how your operating system works, how
computers actually work, right?
It's just a little lower to the It's
like a little closer to the hardware as
all but once you understand that it like
it's a very simple programming language
after that.
Though to be fair, most of what I've
been doing here has just been me editing
configs and Python like Python and uh
configs.
the C environment like the C plot stuff
is going to be different.
I don't understand what this warning is.
I got to get brunch soon.
Oh, I think there's some Docker stuff
that needs to be done.
Yeah, I think there's some small Docker
stuff that needs to be done. That's
fine. I'll set this type of stuff up on
my laptop most likely anyways.
How would we know which episode we're
on? What do you mean which episode?
You'd have to add that like you'd have
to log or track that separately.
Let me go through all three of these
again.
Make it a little faster. We don't need
all this stuff.
Uh, you have to track it. Convert.
There's like nothing built in to say
like what is the index of the episode
you're on.
this is actually the errored one, right?
Yeah, cuz it's like it's stuck here.
Okay.
So, let's just then
Okay, cool. So, here is
here's all our pong data.
And actually, what we need
We just need this to be steps
Why the heck is this way out here?
Why the heck do we have something at
700?
This got to be like outliers. Fine. You
just go over like this, right?
the goal is this will get filled in as
well and we'll have nice frontiers for
everything. All right.
So, at the very least, we fixed some of
the major issues. And as long as I
remember to
like do just a tiny little bit of
checking on these things over the next
few days, we should be able to get to
ourselves to a spot where we have um
like a really nice clean set of
experiments for Pong and Breakout. And
if we have that before I uh am out of
California, then then we should be in a
very good spot to do all the follow-up
analysis. Uh, it's noon. I'm hungry. I'm
going to go buy myself a nice brunch
somewhere
and then I'm going to do uh I got some
business stuff to take care of in the
afternoon. I might do some stuff later
in the evening. I might just start
packing. We will see.
But uh for folks who've been tuning in,
thank you for watching.
All my stuff's at puffer.ai. You can
star the GitHub to help me out for free.
And you can join the Discord to get
involved with development. All my
content is on X as